after Winfrey graduated she moved to
Baltimore Maryland where she did
cuttings during Good Morning America but
soon she was moved to the morning talk
show with co-host Richard share after
seven years a general manager of ABC's
Chicago affiliate Saul Winfrey in an
audition tape
sent in by her producer Deborah DeMaio
at the time her ratings in Baltimore
were better than Phil Donahue's a
national talk show host and she and
DeMaio were hired Winfrey moved to
Chicago Illinois in January of 1984 and
took over as anchor on am Chicago a
morning talk show that was consistently
last in the ratings
she changed the emphasis of the show
from traditional women's issues to
current and controversial debatable
topics after one month the show was even
with Donahue's program three months
later it inched ahead in September of
1985 the program now renamed the Oprah
Winfrey Show was expanded to one hour
as a result Donahue moved to New York
City in 1985 Quincy Jones saw Winfrey on
television and thought she would make a
fine actress in a movie he was
co-producing with director Steven
Spielberg the film was based on the
Alice Walker novel the color purple you
may have heard of it the color purple
her only acting experience until then
had been in a one-woman show the history
of black women through drama and song
which she performed during an African
American theatre festival in 1978 the
popularity of wit free show skyrocket at
the success of the color purple and in
September of 1985 the distributor King
world bought the syndication rights to
air the program in 138 cities a record
for first time syndication that year
although Donahue was being aired on over
200 stations Winfrey won her timeslot by
31%
she drew twice the Chicago audiences
Donahue and carried the top ten markets
in the United States in 1986 Winfrey
received a special award from the
Chicago Academy for the Arts for unique
contributions to the city's artistic
community and was named woman of
achievement by the national organization
of women the Oprah Winfrey Show won
several Emmys for best talk show when
Whitley was honored as the best talk
show host Winfrey formed her own
production company Harpo in August of
1986 to produce the topics that she
wanted to see produced including the
television drama miniseries based on
Gloria nailers the woman of Brewster
place in which wit free was featured
along with Cicely Tyson Robin Givens
Olivia Cole Jackie
Paula Kelly and Lynn Whitfield in 1996
Oprah changed the game when she started
in on-air Reading Club this is one of my
all-time favorite moments I'm having on
television right now you are witnessing
it on September 17th winfrey stood up
and announced she wanted to get the
country reading she told her adoring
fans to hasten to the stores to buy the
book she had chosen they would then
discuss it together on air the following
month the initial reaction was
astonishing the first book the deep end
of the ocean had generated significant
sales for a first novel 68,000 copies
had gone into the stores since June but
between the last week in August when
Winfrey told her plans to the publisher
and the September on-air announcement
Viking printed 90,000 more by the time
the discussion was broadcast on October
18th
there were 750,000 copies in print the
book became a number-one bestseller and
another 100,000 were printed before
February of 97